When it comes to spiders, people generally
know two facts about them- that you swallow
around eight of them per year and that their
blood is bright blue.
Fortunately, the former is absolutely not
true at all, the latter, on the other hand,
is mostly correct.
While it’s certainly true that spiders have
blue liquid in their veins, the reality is
a bit more grounded than is sometimes depicted,
with the fluid a much more reserved shade
of blue-ish green.
Also, thanks to fact that spiders are (generally)
so tiny and contain very little liquid, you’re
not going to see too much of this after smashing
one.
It should also be noted that, unlike humans,
spiders have what is known as an “open circulatory
system.”
Essentially, their blood is allowed to mix
with all the interstitial fluids within their
bodies.
The scientific term for this mixture is hemolymph,
which is a combination of the Greek word for
blood (Haîma) and the Latin word for water
(Lymph) and it’s defined as: “The circulating
fluid in many invertebrates that is functionally
similar to the blood and lymph of vertebrates”
So what in this mixture is causing the fluid
in the spiders to turn blue?
Well, as you may recall, human and indeed
all mammal blood is red because of the presence
of the protein haemoglobin.
The reason haemoglobin makes blood red instead
of say, green is because of the presence of
iron as an oxygen carrying pigment.
(And to quickly debunk another popular blue-blood
myth: No- deoxygenated human blood does not
turn blue.
It turns dark red.
On a related note, the red juice you see in
red meat at the grocery store is not blood.)
Spiders and other arthropods don’t have
haemoglobin in their bodies, rather they have
a protein known as haemocyanin, which contains
copper instead of iron.
However, haemocyanin isn’t bound to any
cells in the creature’s body like haemoglobin
is, instead it just grooves around their circulatory
system at its leisure.
When an oxygen atom binds itself to haemocyanin,
instead of turning a deep shade of red, it
will instead turn a pale blue-ish green, as
copper is wont to do when it oxidises.
The result in spiders is less than impressive
because their bodies contain so little hemolymph
to start with; in larger arthropods though,
this effect can be quite stunning.
For example, the blood of the horseshoe crab
is a delicate shade of baby blue thanks to
the presence of haemocyanin, as is the blood
of lobsters, crayfish and most mollusks like
slugs and snails.
horseshoe-crab-bloodBut what’s even more
fascinating (and unique) about horseshoe crab
blood is a chemical found in the amoebocytes
of its blood.
When this is exposed to a potentially dangerous
foreign bacterium, it will immediately coagulate
around the threat, rendering it harmless without
actually destroying it.
This effect is near instant and the blood
can be used to detect a potential threat even
if it’s diluted as much as one part in a
trillion!
This effect is amazingly useful for detecting
bacterial contamination in things like medicines
and vaccines, or on medical equipment like
needles, pacemakers, and numerous other items
that are required to be sterile.
In fact, no drug on the market today can be
certified by the FDA unless it has been tested
using this exact method (known as the Limulus
amebocyte lysate test, in homage to the species
of the crab- Limulus polyphemus).
It’s by far the best way scientists are
aware of for detecting whether a batch of
medicine or vaccine has been compromised or
not.
As such, the blood of these crabs is worth
a small fortune, selling for around $60,000
per gallon.
If you’re wondering how this blood is harvested,
the crabs (over a half a million per year)
are carefully picked up when they visit the
shore for breeding purposes and taken in cooled
trucks to certified labs where around 30%
of their blood is drained, after which they’re
returned to the sea.
The blood cells are then separated using centrifugation.
Next, the isolated cells are placed in distilled
water where they will eventually burst (see
Why Salt Preserves Meat for why this happens),
releasing the valuable chemical inside.
After being purified, it is then freeze-dried
and stored to be used for testing.
Approximately 85%-97% of the crabs harvested
for this purpose survive and go on their merry
way after, with the crab’s blood levels
returning to normal in under a week.
Even with the relatively good survival rates,
all of this may sound harsh.
But there is one type of animal besides humans
that, at the least, is glad this property
of horseshoe crab blood was discovered in
1956 by Dr. Frederik Bang- namely, the rabbit.
Before the horseshoe crab blood method (LAL)
of detecting microbial contaminants, a much
less accurate and time consuming system involving
testing on live rabbits was used.
(In this rabbit pyrogen test, the rabbits
were injected with a sample of the substance
to be tested.)
So to sum up, if you’re not too technical
in your definition of “blood”, spiders
do have slightly blue fluid coursing through
their bodies.
Also, horseshoe crab blood may someday save
your life, if it hasn’t already.